[Music]
welcome back to harvard unboxed today we
have
our first geforce rtx 2070 review for
you and i suspect like most reviewers we
were
seriously under the pump for this one i
haven't slept for a while now so i'm
very tired
i'm sure i look tired but yeah just
hoping to get through this one
as efficiently as possible for whatever
reason nvidia thought
it was a good idea to hold off sending
out review samples until just a few days
before the release
so that being the case i'm not expecting
my rtx 2070 founders edition graphics
card until later this week probably
friday thankfully msi did come through
for us and save the day last minute
we literally haven't had a minute to
spare on this one i've had around 30
hours in total and i really have used
every last minute to create this content
unfortunately a few hours were wasted on
an unbelievable issue with the flagship
model
the gaming zed card
yeah very odd issue with this card so
right now we aren't on the best of terms
so yeah wasted a bit of time with this
one but i'll talk about that towards the
end of the video i feel like we should
probably get towards the benchmark data
as quick as possible thankfully msi did
also provide
their armor version so we got two cards
from msi and they say that this armor
version will come in closer to the msrp
but
i'll believe that when i see it and
that's not necessarily a dig at msi but
rather
nvidia's
mythical suggested retail prices let's
say on paper the rtx 2070 claims a 500
usmsrp for the board partner cards such
as the armor that is the suggested price
for this card but as i said we'll see
what happens when they go on sale
shortly then there's also the much less
attractive 600 us price for the nvidia
foundation model and that's also what i
believe the price will be for the gaming
zed card
so for
most of the aib models the entry level
ones we are expecting a 30 decrease in
price when compared to the rtx 2080
models
and they have about a 33 decrease in
cuda cores nvidia's own review guide
shows the rtx 2070 easily beating the
gtx 1070 and then the 970 that came
before it though that is a little
misleading as it is priced to compete
with the gtx 1080 and vega 64 so not the
gtx 1070. so anyway the gtx 1080 and
vega 64 will be the models that i focus
our attention on when comparing these
rtx 2070 models
so for all the testing i'm using the msi
rtx 2070 armor and it will be compared
to the fe versions of the 2080 ti and
2080 along with the msi gaming x
versions of the 1080 1080 ti and 1070 as
well as the gaming x trio 1080 ti then
we have the asustrix vega 64 and vega 56
models along with amd's vega 64 liquid
as usual i'm using our corsair gpu test
system inside the crystal series 570x
with the core i7 8700k clocked at 5
gigahertz and 32 gigabytes of vengeance
ddr4 3400 memory for the amd gpus i've
used radeon adrenaline driver 18.10.1
and for nvidia geforce 411.63
while the rtx 2070 gp will be using
driver version 4
16.33 in total we have the results for
20 games but due to limited time i'm
going to discuss the results of just six
of them and they will be six of them all
newly released titles and then i'll
break down the data
for all the games at the end of the
video i'll also include all 61 graphs
over on our patreon page so feel free to
check those out the link will be in the
video description if you want to go and
have a look at any of the results a
little more closely anyway that's pretty
much everything we need to talk about
let's get into the results
first up we have far cry 5 and let's
start with the 1080p results here the
rtx 2070 was a whisker slower than the
gtx 1080 but it was also just nine
percent slower than the rtx 2080 when
comparing the average frame rate that
said we are mostly cpu bound at this
resolution at 1440p the gtx 1080 and rtx
2070 can be seen delivering basically
the same performance this means the 2070
is now 21 slower than the rtx 2080. then
at the 4k resolution we see the 2070 and
1080 delivering identical frame rates
making them 23 slower than the 2080.
this time when testing with assassin's
creed odyssey we do see the rtx 2070
providing a reasonable performance
advantage over the 1080 at 1080p it was
eight percent faster on average so
not a bad result there not exactly
mind-blowing stuff given the price and
we will discuss that more towards the
end of the video the margins extended
out to 13 at 1440p and now the 2070 is
found in the middle of the 1080 and 1080
ti making it just 14 slower than the rtx
2080. again at 4k the 2070 finds itself
between the 1080 and 1080i which means
it was just 30 slower than the 2080 so
a reasonably impressive result here i
suppose
moving on to forza horizon 4 and here
the 2070 is only just able to keep pace
with the 1080 and overall performance
seems quite lackluster despite pushing
higher frame rates at 1080p much the
same as seen at 1440p the 2070 comes in
a few frames behind the gtx 1080 for a
pretty disappointing result it has to be
said
the rtx 2070 isn't able to do any better
at the 4k resolution either as it's only
able to match the 1080 here and that
meant it was 25 slower than the gtx 1080
ti and rtx 2080
testing with shadow of the tomb raider
sees the rtx 2070 again delivered gtx
1080 light performance though it was at
least a few frames faster in this title
at 1080p
moving to 1440p and here we see that the
2070 is just 3fps faster than the 1080
on average
better than 3fps slower i guess
finally at 4k we see similar performance
from the 2070 and 1080 once again this
meant the 2070 was 24 slower than the
2080.
next up we have strange brigade and here
the 2070 provided a nice little seven
percent performance boost over the 1080
at 1080p
then at 1440p we see a slightly larger
10 margin in favor of the rtx 2070 and
this pushed it ahead of vega 64
while it was just behind vega 64 liquid
so overall a nice result here moving to
4k brings things back a bit and now
we're seeing just a six percent margin
of the 2070 average 56 fps while the
1080 was good for 53 fps this meant the
2070 also fell back behind the vega 64
gpus
interestingly monster hunter world is
another title like assassin's creed
odyssey where the rtx 2070
pulls its finger out and actually
delivers some reasonably exciting
numbers here it was nine percent faster
than the gtx 1080 which is a decent
performance uplift it was also 22
percent slow in the rtx 2080
this continued at 1440p or rather
improved as the 2070 is now 11 faster
than the 1080 and 21 slower than the
2080.
things get pulled back a little at 4k
but even so the 2070 still provided
seven percent more frames than the 1080
though it is now 24 slower than the rtx
2080.
when it comes to power consumption the
rtx 2070 is slightly more efficient than
the gtx 1080 pushing total system
consumption to 319 watts this meant
total system consumption was reduced by
16 when compared to the 2080 and 5
compared to the 1080.
now for temperatures we saw a peak of 65
degrees with the msi rtx 2070 with an
ambient room temperature of 21 degrees
so very respectable given that the dual
fans were only spinning at 1300 rpm
this means the armor is a very
cool and quiet entry level model from
msi i should note that south of 60
degrees the fans on this model don't
spin at all so for normal operation it
is completely silent okay so a few mixed
results but it seemed as though for the
most part the geforce rtx 2070 was
delivering gtx 1080 light performance
which is pretty much what we were
expecting to find that said let's see
how the 2070 compared to not just the
1080 but also the 2080 1070 and vega 64
across a 20 game sample here's a look at
how the rtx 2070 compares to the gtx
1080 at 1440p and as we expected it is a
close battle with the 2070 winning by
just a 7 margin on average the only big
wins for the 2070 came in wolfenstein 2
and dirt 4 while it fell behind in
project cars 2 forza horizon 4 and 4
honor
while up to 20 gains are nice to see
sadly at this stage these are outlier
results and as the 7 average figure
suggests single digit gains are what you
can typically expect to find
when compared to the more expensive rtx
2080 the new 2070 model was on average
18 percent slower at 1440p which is
about what you'd expect from a gpu with
33 fewer cuda cores especially with a
few cpu limited results added to the
equation like what we see in war thunder
and prey for example we did see up to a
28 performance deficit in for honor and
25 percent enforcer horizon 4 but as you
can see for the most part the 2070 was
around 16 to 22 percent slower for gtx
1070 owners the jump in performance is
decent but really nothing new if you've
been holding out on getting a gtx 1080
for the past two years well you'll still
be holding out on average the rtx 2070
was 27 faster but again for gtx 1070
owners that margin will fail to impress
given the price tag
then we have the vega 64 comparison and
here the rtx 2070 was 10 faster than
average so
not much more to really say here in
terms of performance the geforce rtx
um yeah it's as lackluster as we're
expecting to be honest given what we saw
with the 2080 we predicted that the 2070
would be around 10 faster than the gtx
1080 and it turns out we were pretty
much on the money with that one as we
saw a 7 improvement over the 20 games
tested had the msrp been around four
hundred dollars we'd be a lot more
excited about the numbers just seen
claiming the rtx 2070 as the new value
king
but at 500 u.s it's basically a gtx 1080
refresh
with a few extra bells and whistles
but at the moment you can't really take
advantage of those so yeah for now they
don't amount to too much
right now you can pick up a gtx 1080 for
as little as 450 usd and getting one for
under 500 isn't particularly difficult
i'm also seeing in gtx 1070 ti models
for as low as 400 us and there's plenty
of models are selling for around 430 us
and well we know if you overclock those
you're looking at gtx 1080 light
performance which means that an
overclocked gtx 1070 ti won't be much
slower than what we've seen here from
the rtx 2070.
unfortunately right now we don't yet
fully know
what the rtx 2070 graphics cards will
retail for when they hit shelves
tomorrow and what we do know though is
that you can pre-order the foundation
model from nvidia for 600. and there is
a single aib model up for sale on newegg
and that's a gigabyte card which is also
selling for six hundred dollars
so will we see any models for as low as
500 u.s the actual aib msrp
well
before pondering that one for too long
let's look at a few cost per frame
graphs
looking at the msrp figures and yes we
know these aren't real prices for the
most part anymore because nvidia is
abusing the hell out of the msrp but
let's just look at them anyway
just in case we see some pricing justice
over the next few months
at the msrp we see that the aib price
for the rtx 2070 sees it off around six
percent more value than the gtx 1080.
that said when compared to vega 56 and
the gtx 1070 you get slightly worse in
terms of value despite being outright
faster it's also around 13 more cost
effective than the rtx 2080.
that said pay close attention to the fe
msrp
as that sees the rtx 2070 come in at a
cost of six dollars and 12 cents per
frame and that makes it 13 more
expensive in the gtx 1080.
again keep that in mind as we move on
okay so here are the more true to life
numbers and i'm going to ignore the
foundation pricing here because in
reality fe and aib pricing it's pretty
much the same thing here we see that in
reality the rtx 2070 is likely going to
cost around six dollars per frame based
on our data and that makes it worse
value than the gtx 1080 ti and even
vague 64. this right here is why we've
been less than excited about the new
geforce 20 series at the aib msrp
they're just okay at the real msrp
though they're a hard pass
not sure what more i can really say at
this point it really comes down to the
price and i'm expecting gamers will have
to pay around six hundred dollars u.s
for an rtx 2070 graphics card which
makes it a very
very average product uh even with any
well even with a lack of real
competition from amd it's still quite
lackluster and in my opinion unexciting
at the expected prices meanwhile over in
my neck of the woods which
is australia
stay
i've been told by a few different
retailers that we can expect the
absolute cheapest models to cost about
950 dollars
uh so yeah that's not great and they
also suggest that most models will be
priced closer to one thousand dollars
some even creeping over one thousand
dollars
and that means even the absolute
cheapest cards will cost at least 12
percent more
than the
current gtx 1080 models
some retailers did suggest that they're
starting to see a price increase for the
pascal graphics cards slowly pulling
them more in line with the newer
competing touring graphics cards and
this is something we predicted would
happen last month when reviewing the rtx
2080 and 2080 ti the cash grabs in full
swing now people we knew what the latest
geforce 20 series was all about before
it even hit shelves
so while disappointing we've known this
would be the situation for months now on
a more personal note i was very
disappointed that nvidia chose to shaft
harbor unboxed on this release and it
sounds like
we weren't the only media outlet getting
shaft with this rtx 2070 launch nvidia
failed to provide us with an rtx 2070
sample there's no reason why they
couldn't and why they shouldn't have we
really should have had one in our hands
a week in advance there's no reason why
the cards weren't ready and yeah
couldn't be in our hands
with a reasonable amount of time ahead
of this release so we can take our time
and really put together a good review
anyway hopefully this content hasn't
appeared too rushed despite the fact
that it was quite rushed
yeah very disappointed that we had to
rely on msi coming through
uh less than well just over a day uh
before the review was set to go live
anyway i will have my foundation
graphics card in the next few days i
won't be doing any content with that
though i will test it for thermals power
consumption and some baseline numbers
just so i do have some baseline figures
to compare two cards such as these
and then i'll ship it off to tim and
then he'll put it in his test beds and
use it for
game optimization guides and whatever
else tim feels like doing with it oh and
i should also note making the deadline a
little more challenging was msi's rtx
gaming zed model i did touch on this at
the start of the video but i didn't want
to go into too many details because i
knew you guys would probably just want
to see the results but yeah ran into a
really really strange issue with this
card for whatever reason it refused to
boot up with pcie 3.0 times 16 enabled
so it was defaulting to x4 which was
severely limiting the bandwidth the card
had access to via the pci express slot
and that caused me to waste a lot of
time because i didn't know that was the
problem initially i just couldn't work
out what was going on the first few
hours i was stumped by the odd
performance i was seeing
titles that weren't particularly
sensitive to the nerfing of the pci
express bandwidth were performing
reasonably well like what you saw in the
video
five seven percent maybe up to ten
percent faster than the gtx 1080 which
is about what i was expecting so that
seemed right then in other games it was
like 20 percent slower so i knew that
probably wasn't right
and yes so i spent a lot of time trying
to work out what was going on there
tried different test system still the
same thing in a different test system
with a different motherboard mind you
fresh install of windows fresh drivers
wasted many hours as you can imagine and
then i noticed in gpuz when i was
checking things like the drivers and
what the gpu was clocked at the memory
sort of stuff i noticed that the pcie
spec wasn't quite right sometimes that
happens in gpus he thought it might have
been a bug it's a new card but then
ultimately i did end up digging this
card out because i'd given up on this
one i should have really slotted this
one in earlier but i thought it really
wouldn't be the card i mean the gold
pins are all really clean they look nice
the cards brand new i believe it's been
tested by msi anyway
put the armor in and straight away it
reported as uh pci express 3.0 x 16 and
performance was restored in the games or
it was much lower to where i was
expecting it to be so then i madly got
on with testing this for the next
10 12 hours i don't really recall like i
said i haven't really slept
uh and yeah now we're done
anyway to wrap this thing up uh
as you've probably guessed i'm not
particularly impressed with the geforce
rtx 2070 pricing which is a shame
because well apart from the issues i had
with this one it is a really nice
looking card i was super impressed with
this card especially if you can get it
in close to the msrp because the
performance was excellent it ran cool
and quiet so yeah they're some really
great looking cards here from msi they
have quite a few other different models
as well but we've got two of them here
as you've seen and yeah it's a real
shame that we're not terribly excited
about these new graphics cards because a
lot of the a lot of nvidia's partners
look like they've put together some
really nice looking cards
having said all that
let me know what you guys think have i
been a bit too harsh on the rtx 2070
have i not been harsh enough
i don't know let me know whether i've
got it right or wrong in the comment
section below oh and finally before i
forget i haven't talked about ray
tracing or dlss
and well that's because there's nothing
to talk about i'm not going to go over
all that again we covered we've covered
all this stuff so when there's something
to talk about we'll talk about it uh tim
will provide a detailed recap on the rtx
situation i think in thursday's video so
a couple of days you'll see that and
then before then he will be doing a full
recap of gpu pricing just like you did
with cpu pricing uh yesterday so it'll
be worth keeping up for and we will have
more solid information on rtx 2070
pricing for that video and with that i
am going to end this one if you did
enjoy the video be sure to the like
button much appreciated subscribe for
more content if you did enjoy this video
then that's a good way of seeing more
videos like this we do a video pretty
much every day
and if you really appreciate the way we
do our unbox and you want to get in our
ear and talk to us at any time of the
day then become a patreon member because
you can get in our discord chat you can
watch our monthly live streams we'll be
doing a
series of monthly live streams next week
so yeah that's coming up in one week's
time they're always a lot of fun we
address a lot of questions
and there's going to be a hell of a lot
of stuff to talk about on this month's
live stream
so anyway i am starting to get blurry
vision i need to go to bed uh so yeah my
my name's steve
thanks for watching i'll see you again
next time
[Music]
you